[Music]
well you've waited all week it's time
now for final exam where the best
informed people in the news business sit
across one another at a set to determine
who's the best informed person in the
news business this week contestants Fox
correspondent Kristen Fisher and the
host special report Bret Baier now you
know I you never miss an episode so of
course you know the rules but for our
viewers just tuning and I'm gonna repeat
them this is old hat for you and some
buzzers I ask the questions the first
one to buzz in gets to answer the
question you must wait until I finish
asking the question in order to answer
it you can answer one sec Knology by
saying your name each correct answer is
worth one point every incorrect detracts
the point best of five wins does that
make sense yes outstanding good luck my
lady and gentlemen question one the art
world was stunned this week when a
painting by the graffiti artist Banksy
was sold at auction something very odd
happened once the gavel came down
what was it bret baier no one bid no one
bid did no one bid on the famous
graffiti artist Banksy - the tape
[Applause]
this work of art now it's being shredded
they believe it actually adds about 50
percent more to the value that's
actually quite a brilliant art world or
anything alright question to you know
what that says something good about both
of you that you're not watching art
auctions during yeah got work to do
alright this is a multiple choice
question number two singer Taylor Swift
has become political as you know she is
urging her fans to vote against
Tennessee Republican Marsha Blackburn
next month the president responded to
this news by saying of swift one of
three things was it a Taylor Swift is
overrated be I like her music less now
or see lock her up Kristen Fisher be he
likes it 25% less I always lock her up
we'll find out to the tape please dr.
Blackburn is doing a very good job in
Tennessee
there's an order thing about her
[Music]
watching all of those all this tapes
finally roughly 25% less fantastic
alright question three also taken from
the world of pop culture kanye west
under fire today for showing all of
America his iPhones passcode while on
live television
well he met with the president in the
White House Kanye took out his phone and
hit the same number six times in order
to unlock it what very unsecure number
was it bret baier zero now I don't know
how many zeros it was I think of zero
zero zero zero but all zeros zeros was
it all zeroes judges say that's enough
zeros what we might be looking at the
comeback story of the week 1 2 0 1 2 0
that's right you are back into like the
stasis hoose a question for starting
this week which former American
president will come to life in the form
of a 3d hologram here in Washington
Kristen Fisher Reagan Reagan Reagan an
airport now a hologram
Ronald Reagan every four years almost
every Republican presidential hopeful
invokes the spirit of President Reagan
now at his library that spirit has
become a virtual reality three Holograms
of President Reagan make their first
public appearance
this is connecting you guys should have
holograms for in here you know that way
you don't take more time I know what
let's get that Newark on final question
this one also multiple-choice Frontier
Airlines the airline of the West kicked
off an Orlando woman from one of its
places this week after she boarded the
plane with a prohibited prohibited
animal this multiple choice what kind of
animal was it was it a a bike
Kristen loses a point it goes to Bret oh
I could get the right answer you get a
nine up in which case we need a
tiebreaker unfair but those are the
rules it's like the electoral college
it's in the Constitution Kristen you
can't change it okay so Brad did she
refuse to fly without a a Python be a
squirrel or see a raccoon a squirrel was
it be a squirrel a woman was kicked off
a flight after bringing an emotional
support squirrel onto the plane Frontier
Airlines only allows dogs or cats I got
here okay okay so we have to go the
tiebreaker we always have the same
tiebreaking question okay and if you
watch the show before you know it since
the test of that - yes yes that buzzers
ready here's the tiebreaker what is the
capital of Burkina Faso the African
nation Burkina Faso seriously this is
the every time has anybody ever gotten
it no well I don't think it's gonna
happen tonight either I don't have it
it's wagga dugu see that was gonna go
here you're not sure you know what our
judges are saying in this rare instance
it's never before in C oh wait they're
saying we have one more question what is
the capital of Madagascar Madagascar
Madagascar that is no reasonably
informed person should have to know
either one of those answers therefore
for the first time in the history of
this show we have a split decision we
have an actual tie in which both of you
get a medal both of you claim the
victory both you go home proud Wow you
know this is quite the Millennial it
really
one Eric whemple mug but this also and
they're saying this to me now
this requires at some point in the next
12 months you must come back for rematch
fantastic share amazing look at this